hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom please excuse this new living
room I'm in the process of moving that's
why I'm drinking tonight so I get a lot
of messages from you teens you watch the
show saying that not necessarily a
parent and you don't necessarily drink
wine but you use this show as almost a
sex ed that you don't learn in school so
I decided for this episode let's just go
full sex ed let's talk about what it's
like to lose your virginity
I mean awkward episode so first let's
define what virginity actually is when
people say you lose your virginity the
first thought is penis vagina but there
are so many different types of sex there
are so many different types of
sexualities you might not necessarily be
heterosexual and so virginity means a
whole different thing to you like the
definition of virginity that first comes
to people's minds I think is just the
physical definition there's a whole
other emotional part that goes along
with it so what we're talking about is
both so that being said now that we've
defined what virginity is let's talk
about how you know you're ready I
remember when I was in high school all
my friends started losing their
virginity I was the last one and so I
felt all this pressure to not be the
last one anymore I feel like there's
almost this fear and kind of scramble in
high school to lose your virginity in
high school because maybe in college if
you're still a virgin that it's just
never gonna happen
up 18 you're cut off you can never have
sex no that's not the case I know plenty
of people who lost their virginity in
college and even well after college and
it was fine it will happen when it's
right for you so if you're in high
school and you're worried about it or
even in college and worried about it
it's nothing just stress over it
eventually it's gonna happen so don't
put too much pressure on making sure it
happens when it's happening for
everybody else so now that you know that
you're ready to lose your virginity
let's first debunk a couple myths so
first people always think that losing
their virginity is going to hurt because
I think with the first time you're
having sex you're just like okay just
like put something in
then over time you learn about this
thing called foreplay and it's very
necessary it gets the juices flowing
it gets everything going get everything
prepped and ready for penetration yeah
that sounds and when you just go
straight up like wow there's nothing
there to like use it in that's like
running and diving down a dry
slip-and-slide you got to make sure
there's another water you got to let the
sprinklers run for a little bit before
you just like go headfirst into it good
metaphor next you will not become
obsessed with the person who you lose
your virginity to you I feel like it's a
very high school myth I remember all
these guys in high school would talk
about like no I don't want to take her
virginity because she's just gonna be
obsessing me until the day she dies
special do you think you [ __ ] are
like I know there are some people who
lose their virginity and they end up
marrying that person but it's not
because they lost their virginity to
them it's because there's a whole lot of
other factors that make them want to
marry that person so the guy I lost my
virginity to was a friend and when it
was over we did not start dating it's
not like I developed this weird
obsession with him and like to this day
like scrapbook pictures of his life from
his Facebook of course there's an
emotional attachment or connection but
that person's not gonna just Pine over
you for the rest of their life don't pat
yourself on the back too hard
next the myth of once you've started the
act of losing your virginity
you can't stop there's this feeling of
like oh well you're already and they're
into it there's this expectation I've
already started so I might as well
finish that's [ __ ] you can stop
whenever you want for any reason for no
reason at all if you just don't feel
like it and if your partner is not
receptive to that and kick them to the
curb because that's not okay and the
last myth is that the way you lose your
virginity is gonna dictate the rest of
your sex life where does not the case of
whatsoever the way you lose your
virginity is just this one little
awkward push into
another realm of being if you were bad
if you were awkward if it was
embarrassing you're only gonna get
better from there it's like the first
time I did karaoke it was really weird
and I held the microphone out too far so
nobody could hear and it was super
awkward and I stood up there in front of
the entire bar looking like a [ __ ]
idiot
now when I do karaoke I know I need two
glasses of wine before I start I know I
need to practice in the bathroom a
couple times and then I get on the stage
my [ __ ] rocket just like stags so
last let's talk about doing the damn
thing so first thing you want to do is
go through a mental checklist do I feel
emotionally ready am I physically ready
do I trust this person am i in a
location that makes me feel safe am I in
a situation that makes me feel safe do I
have the proper protection or am i
taking the proper precautions and do it
on the kick-ass playlist to play while I
do this thing because that songs gonna
remind you about losing your virginity
for the rest of your life for me it was
Destiny's Child bills great song I'm
glad it doesn't play on the radio much
anymore when I lost my virginity I was
at a party it was like kind of an
opportune moment
so my first time wasn't this whole like
romantic like rose petals scattered over
the bed like box of chocolates laying on
the nightstand it was fine it was
enjoyable I have no regrets in sunson
I've had better sex I've had worse sex
if you're watching this and curious
about actually losing over to me and
kind of unsure about it I hope that this
helped I hope that you learn something
of it do you feel a little less fearful
of it at the end of the day ultimately
it comes down to you and when it happens
for you I hope that it happens in the
way that you want so go get em tiger
[Music]
I was kind of weird that's all I got for
today I'm handing your friendly
neighborhood wide mom and if there's a
topic you want me to talk about in a
future episode leave it in the comments
or you can still text me I read them all
just so you know I don't necessarily
respond because I get flooded with a lot
of them but I do read every single one
of them so if there's anything you're
curious about shoot me text and in the
meantime I'm gonna go listen to some
Destiny's Child if you know what I mean
till next time
[Music]